welcome to this video playing judge meek
judge me totally non plus that have no
game against him he said it's an would
handle and I haven't played him a couple
of times probably this must be with some
some a widow with accounts yeah okay I
tried be four for a change and we have a
10 man or Seussian and wow I think it
was Bishop before something I had really
have no idea what's going on the after
after d6r something in that regard and
probably able to make up things oh here
if five isn't e5 good here okay
my t5 looks strange now maybe that's his
son his idea but makes a strange
impression okay I hey can actually go to
G form and maybe I should have taken
with a bishop tough the same Queen B 6
looks like the relatively best choice I
don't want to move the bishop to g1 and
maybe it was okay that this looks kind
of logical now I don't really see why I
see what is he thinking about isn't
queen bee a tag isn't taking the only
move Queen B ADA thought Bishop c5
should be really good okay
ha
amazing so if i take it yeah I
understand yeah interesting but take it
BP takes mm-hmm okay yeah you should
never pre-move I never expected that one
we should be six was just excellent of
course but I thought okay you should
never pre-move I was just thinking be
texas the only move anyway okay psyllium
very silly shouldn't pre-move ever if
not in this not in situations like that
yeah B takes was more interesting we
should be six year was of course much
better in comparison occupying this
important square and they are preventing
things like that and so on was just the
farm and far more logical move
hmm f5 okay so yes to do something like
that there is no there is no slow move
now let's kick it back then support this
this pawn chain yeah that's a very
dominating peas on c5 and have a very
simple threat Bishop g2
it's actually a question if I should
ever really take them pen term okay
that's that is no question anymore
Philly hi this is just a really
fantastic position the bishops are just
fantastic here k Bishop age 5 or king of
to my let's start with King f2
okay let's see what is the best way to
to play here ok let's start with this
threatening but should be seven check
just make sure that the sea point is not
moving yeah there were many many nice
ways to play with hard to say what was
best one simple but very important point
is that his night is is just great here
on age six yeah here can just check it i
think and then march march up with a
king it should actually win i think
let's let's look let's see it should win
King King King walks up
don't see how he how he holds this maybe
Bishop f8 I could have done it without
the king bishop f8 and Bishop f7 traps
than might that was actually better yep
let's do it like that Bishop f7 will
trap tonight black resign yeah King King
Joffrey was a bit silly I could have
done that one of earlier yeah the
position out of the opening was just a
complete disaster ya hear that was a hit
him he really has to play beat eggs I
mean to have some kind of idea of a
counter play I mean I think I'm better
but it's not not as one-sided yet here I
should really go here I am but ok Bishop
p.m. yeah p5 is a move it gives away the
dark squares completely and here here we
are approaching territory where why
disgusting strategically winning this is
just so strong the night on c5 and then
huge problems all around
yeah that's it's just one possibility
this is also an idea putting the sea end
intending this winning the exchange
stiphu called actually to prevent that
those bishops will win one of the rooks
for our foreign exchange yeah it's just
it's too much the bishops and the jack
bunch of weaknesses that there are the
itm bishop evade immediately was a bit a
bit more precise but it's it's really I
can also walk up here with the king
there is no just entirely dominating
expositions black pieces are really
remarkably remarkably bad okay thanks
for watching